we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this uh voicemail is very interesting
in terms of what it um suggests could
become the dividing line
between the vaccinated and the
unvaccinated in the future take a listen
to this
hey there david this is lance calling
from san jose
listening to your show today when you're
talking about republican reluctance to
get the vaccine to
whatever deny the deny covet or to own
the libs
i have a crazy prediction for probably
later this year
yeah that covet deaths will have to be
reported
based on red cove deaths and blue
coveted deaths
or trump supporter kova deaths and trump
announce reporter i mean really if
they're really gonna
not get the vaccine oh boy uh
i guess stay away from alabama and
places like that yeah so i mean listen
you're never really going to be able to
say red or blue coveted deaths in the
sense that we won't know the political
orientation of those who
who continue dying even after the
vaccines are widely available
and you can't really go by state because
you know
a texas coveted death could be some
liberal in
austin or it could be you know what
you're not going to know that but the
point is a good one
even if we won't know for sure if
the most anti-vaccine group in the
united states the two most anti-vaccine
groups are republican men
uh and trump supporters you at a certain
point
will have a significantly higher degree
of protection from the virus
among non-trump supporters and
non-republicans
and it could well be the case that in a
year or whenever vaccines are widely
available
maybe we already have a booster that
accounts for the variance
the group that will be
disproportionately unvaccinated
may well be republicans right wingers
and trump supporters
and you could see a situation in the u.s
where like 80 percent of the deaths
85 percent of the deaths are right
wingers that certainly could be the case
if the anti-vax movement is going to
continue on covid
remember other anti-vac like measles has
left in right-wing anti-vaxerism
uncovered the anti-vaxerism is far more
on the right than the left
left you could indeed start to see that
split and
i don't want anybody to die i don't want
anybody to get sick even if they're
ignorant anti-vaxx republicans
so i would take no pleasure in that uh
let's just hope
people realize the importance of getting
vaccinated we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today fox news is
claiming
that reports about the georgia trump
phone calls were wrong
and that now everybody is having to
retract the stories on them that's not
what's going on i'll explain the story
to you on the bonus show
we will also talk about you know for all
the discussion of the regular minimum
wage
the tipped minimum wage has been just
over two dollars an hour
for decades and it is not getting a lot
of discussion in the minimum wage
discussions
and then lastly the fcc is cracking down
on robo calls with
record fines will this make a difference
i have some robocall stories to tell as
well
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com